I started when I was about five years
old and I carried the cards everywhere
that I went and I didn't really know
what to do with them but they just felt
right I mean early on I would read about
all the people I looked up to and you
know that was kind of like my college
was finding people that did things that
I was really amazed by and then learning
as much as I could in London I lived in
a glass box for 44 days with nothing but
water it was for me one of the most
difficult things I've ever done
need motivation watch the top ten would
believe nation what's up at seven my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I wanna see exploded onto the
world so let's get your motivation to
attend and get you believing in you grab
a snack and chew on today's lessons from
a man who went from being raised by
single mom and getting his start as a
street performer to setting multiple
world records and being recognized as
one of the greatest magicians of all
time he's David Blaine and here's my
take on his top ten rules to success joy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one find your path you believe
that you see the card and you actually
believe that you see me place the card
inside right
yes no it's always gonna be right here
let me show you again look so looks no
but look no but watch cuz it's an
optical illusion so you know what I'm
doing so look you see the card here and
then you really believe that it's going
inside right no it's an optical illusion
so that you saw magic how are your
influences life like how did how did
that start I started when I was about 5
years old and I carried cards everywhere
that I went and I didn't really know
what to do with them but they just felt
right looks like you learn all these
little moves with the cards and in the
hands they just feel good so I didn't
know that that existed and then a
librarian was really little walked me
through a self working mathematical
trick I did it to my mother and she
reacted like it was incredible and then
I started to love performing because you
would get the reaction so part of it is
just how it feels in the hands and love
apart is math logic science and the
other part is a performance aspect so
all those are very addicting you see how
the cards kind of just move across right
now if I do that really fast you won't
see it so look I'll do it with this card
really fast with the 9 of diamonds I
just shoot did you see that see the 9
rule number two make it happen see that
18 I think it was and I don't know if
this was a milestone or not but you I
believe this is when he jumped a
turnstile done some trouble for that
yeah can you tell me what I was doing I
was doing magic and restaurants and it
started as a waiter where I would do
magic and then I people wanted to come
back and just see me doing magic so I
started walking up and down parka and
I'm trying to get different fancy
restaurants to hire not hire me let me
do magic to the people that were dining
and then they would tip me as I started
doing that I started getting hired by
wealthy New Yorkers to do their parties
and things like that one night I was I
jumped over a turnstile and that's when
Giuliani was sweeping everybody so I I
got locked up but as I was going there I
kept breaking out of the cuffs with a
cop so they liked it loved that by the
way I'm actually like hey guys these
aren't working I mean how do they
respond to that
yeah no no they're all good I don't they
know that I'm not really a threat but I
don't you know so it's good there's
anybody they know they just have to go
through the motions yeah so I get put in
central booking and central booking is
crazy it's like everybody's in and out
of Riker's so it's like a tough room and
you're being moved from one cell to
another and there's like 40 guys in
there and I'm like man I'm gonna get my
ass kicked so they're the four biggest
guys are sitting on the ground playing
spades so I walk up to them and grab the
deck of cards from them and I'm like let
me show you some like the you know
they're they're ready to really kill me
ya and I start doing magic and then what
happened was they started to go crazy
and these are the toughest guys in the
cell so then the whole cell is around me
you know thirty guys or 20-some guys all
going crazy and then the guards come in
and the everybody was reacting to me
doing that like they were all going
crazy again I was like whoa so these
people on Park Ave know these super
powerful people and then in prison these
guys the reactions are
amazing and so similar I want to show
that so that became the impetus for the
first TV show which was called street
magic you know the guys that do
three-card Monte right all right all
right this is that game for you right
now no money no money it's to just
pretend so three cards you slash hold
your fingers like this hold your fingers
like this look watch this card right
remember diamonds forget ace just
diamonds
hold it palpable kardea what what card
is that look yeah together name it name
it what is it diamonds this time it's
look show it to them make sure it's all
right show it to them to bingo bingo
bingo bango cool man hold it like this
look lower lower lower watch this one
same thing just remember hearts forget a
start watch this switch ready see I
switched it look I'll do it again see it
switch back just switch twice so quickly
are you yes switch twice like I'll do it
so you could see it look here some of
the other boarders I'm teaching you
right now that's how I do it hold it
tight that make it impossible a without
looking at it what would you bet on
hearts of diamonds but you got a mark
but pretend bet would you bet hearts
here hearts here or could I impress you
if the heart was on top diamond was on
bottom hearts on top like yeah don't
turn your hand over
okay head turning hand over
rule number three never quit have you
ever done a trip that didn't work almost
every single one in front of people it
failed something well the good news
about doing magic is and I think like
rappers too it's like you never know
where the end is because it's up to him
so it's you you can keep improvising and
going so there's never a failure unless
you quit so if you keep going there's
not a failure just keep changing and
moving rule number four challenge
yourself as a magician I try to create
images that make people stop and think I
also try to challenge myself to do
things that doctors say are not possible
I was buried alive in New York City and
a coffin buried alive in a coffin in
April 1999 for a week I lived there
nothing but water and it ended up being
so much fun that I decided I could
pursue doing more of these things the
next one is I froze myself in a block of
ice for three days and three nights in
New York City that one was way more
difficult than I had expected
the one after that I stood on top of a
hundred foot pillar for 36 hours I began
to hallucinate so hard that the
buildings that were behind me started to
look like big animal heads so next I
went to London in London I lived in a
glass box for 44 days with nothing but
water it was for me one of the most
difficult things I've ever done but it
was also the most beautiful
there were so many skeptics especially
the press in London that uh they started
flying cheeseburgers on helicopters
around my box to tempt me so I felt very
validated when the New England Journal
Medicine actually used the research for
science rule number five be fearless so
when I was 19 or 20 or something like
that
I was I was at the airport and my bag
was missing and I saw a whole bunch of
identical bags coming out and there was
all these guys dressed in identical
jumpers and I was like I think you guys
have one of my bags because I have the
exact same bag it was a to ebay they
said go go ask him knock on the window
and it was a limousine a white limo
parked out front with tinted windows and
I knocked on the window and the thing
rolls down and mike tyson's there was
fist up you got a problem and that's
like it I was like holy Sh
like you're like my favorite person I
grew up without about you know so she
says just like jumper deliver with and
we drive to the hotel he's staying at
and in and I'm doing magic terminal
where it's it's amazing and along the
way he says to me says you know it
wasn't supposed to be the heavyweight
champ because like I didn't have I
wasn't tall enough and enough long arms
he's like but I had nothing to lose and
when you have nothing to lose you have
everything to gain and I was kind of
like that was like another like great
piece of information from Mike Tyson
rule number six this is a little bit of
a gross one amaze your customers this is
my right hand this is a hand that I used
to do everything
[Music]
this is a nice big this hasn't been
switched in around this has been here
the whole time is that true yeah do you
want to make sure it's actually what it
seems to me yeah that's definitely what
it seems a bit
[Music]
this is complete mind over body
[Music]
[Music]
see how it really looks it's going
through the hand yeah Kent and does it
really look like it Thanks it is yeah oh
god no oh there's no blood
see this is ultimately what they want to
see Kanye see that
[Music]
look ultimately in magic that's what
people care about
it's that see see that's really what
they want to see
[Music]
[Music]
that is through your hand there's no
blood
why this is a part that could be messy
by the way do you want to just feel it
make sure it's actually and I lost my
erection and tired pull it straight out
grab it and just pull it right out
good go ahead just pull back at Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
hold my grades girls
just hold me steady oh go ahead pause
for four oh nothing oh no blood nothing
I got promised it went through your hand
it feels like it went through hand this
is not a glove it doesn't retract
oh my god guys have a pretty drab day
Wow Wow that's the craziest thing I've
ever seen in my life obviously I can't
you're out of your mind and the most
[Music]
you're just out of your minds I'm in the
most beautiful way possible is my god
rule number seven go with the flow I
said two weeks in your bag right now and
there was a ham sandwich she'd be like
oh wow that's a cool trick how did how
did he get the sandwich in my bag
right if he said I was hungry right now
I'd really love a sandwich and then you
said reach in your pocket and now
there's a ham sandwich oh then it's not
a trick then there's something much more
interesting and that's really the
concept for great magic I think it's
about timing it's about interacting and
being able to go with the flow rule
number eight find mentors one of the
best things Brian taught me there he was
he was an early mentor to me one of the
quotes his dad gave to him is always
surround yourself with people that will
inspire you or help you grow and that
was just a great piece of advice and I'm
I took that very seriously and pursued
people that I've looked up to or that I
admired and tried to learn things from
them since I didn't have really you know
father figure anything like that I mean
early on I would read about all the
people I looked up to and you know that
was kind of like my college was finding
people that did things that I was really
amazed by and then learning as much as I
could and then what I started doing is I
started finding all the books on Nobel
Prize winners and then in literature
specifically and then I would read what
books they recommended and then I would
read the books that they recommend then
on the back of that book it would be
what this book was influenced by so I
started going through lots of that stuff
rule number nine work hard I'm actually
friends with Copperfield okay yeah okay
I get phone calls from sometimes at like
3:00 a.m. okay about nothing it's like
David yeah yeah what are we gonna do
about this thing like what do you mean
you know and then he'll have this whole
idea for something that's insane that
should be done and magic but it's always
brilliant so the guy you know I think
everybody works pretty hard I think you
should be a magician it looks really
easy
you think what Copperfield does is he
walks out there and it's you know he
does it but that guy works harder than
anybody I know you know what I mean yeah
like he really really works and it's
hard that guys most most shows that you
guys see it's like people do like 278
years yeah last year Copperfield did 600
shows and rule number 10 the last one we
for some very special bonus clips and my
personal favorite master your craft
think of any card in the deck great I'll
hold the deck you're thinking of a card
do I know what card you're thinking of
your card just left the back just now
look through the deck your card isn't
there
good what yeah it's not there you won't
see it there now it's nowhere
here's a little dude Anderson do me a
favor grab grab a piece of grab a piece
of fruit for me like a one that we can
open up yeah grab a piece of fruit good
whatever and is there can we can we cut
this Queen can we take a knife and put
it right there yeah yeah can put it
right here say your card out loud kind
of hurts my heart can you turn this
sideways yes I can cut right through it
let me not hit your hand let's do hold
it
see inside see this see how there's a
card in the orange no way now there's
one card inside please remove it
take it out pull it out open it up para
something
oh that's no no that's okay
now I've got two very special bonus
clips from David Blaine on how to chunk
things down and love what you do but
before that I want to know what did you
learn from this video what is your
commitment of the day
don't just watch another video take some
action what is that going to be you
watch this video right down below the
action that you are going to change in
your business or in your life I'm really
curious to find out thank you so much
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever here one where it is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clips
what is your secret reserve of strength
when you feel that your body or mind
can't push through that's that's a
really good question so what I what I do
is a lot of us based on numbers so I
create an eye and I run it across the
board so it's like if I'm if I'm gonna
run a 10k I make sure that I get not
just to the six point two but I'll go
always further like maybe two seven or
I'll pick a number that's important and
then I have these superstitions that if
I don't get to this number something
terrible is gonna happen
so by committing to this the this almost
superstition that's that's based on
numbers you can use you know the halfway
mark like okay I'm gonna get to twenty
two days of a fast but I know I have
forty four days so first I reach the 22
day mark and then I start counting
backwards I said I already did half so
that happens so now I could pretend I'm
starting fresh so I have 22 days to go
so let me get to another 11 days let me
get through in and it's just it's
basically just breaking it down in in
little chunks but making sure that you
get to that finish line didn't you do
something or have a very similar
superstition when you're a kid in school
really like your school bus you have to
do certain things pull leaf off a tree
or oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I would stop
and there'd be a leaf that was just out
of reach when you jump and I just keep
jumping and jumping and I have to put
something down until I got that they're
just little things so but it's weird
because when when I for me it was almost
like training because I'd set a goal
that was very difficult and then I just
wouldn't quit until I got it and part of
it was a superstition of doing this
ridiculous thing that has no meaning but
just not quitting until it's done why do
you love doing this so much what is it
that motivates you to do this it's so
many different things but one of my
favorite things is even though I act
like I'm not reacting when I'm done
doing magic and you see people reacting
I live off of their reaction so it's
like you know it went like lunch when
she just wanted to screw that's what I
live for so I play it pretty casual but
I love seeing people light up or just be
become pretty you know raw and then the
other thing about it is a digital
fixation like a love of just playing
with cards and manipulating things and
then also learning new things that seem
impossible but actually how to do them
so there's so many levels to it if you
have to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums your Apple
that would be to like a little beacon
hey believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]